[Music]
on this Saturday night stuck in China
hundreds of Canadians stranded in the
epicenter of the new coronavirus crisis
when I improve health plus the new
problems sparked by the deadly virus we
need to support each other and stay
united post president britain depressed
down beaten i feel absolutely delighted
the new reality for the UK and the EU
heading to the big league the tiny
toronto team with international
ambitions
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us
countries around the world are closing
their borders to rivals from China as it
struggles to control the spread of the
new coronavirus today Australia joined
the list of countries denying entry to
all foreign visitors who recently
visited China the Canadian government
has not said if it plans to implement
similar restrictions the corona virus
has killed more than 300 people and
infected more than 13,000 others the
bulk of them in China there are
Canadians in China wanting out and
they've turned to Ottawa for help
Abigail Beeman reports on their struggle
as this health emergency gets worse
they're not aware of what's going on but
they do pick up on our stress Meighan
Millward her husband and two young kids
traveled from Montreal to visit her
in-laws in rural whoo Bay now they're
stuck there are no toilets and we
obviously knew that ahead of time
because we come here every year but with
a very sensitive health situation the
longer we stay here without like running
water and proper hygiene is a rather
than more worried we become worried
about a shortage of medical help and
about splitting up her family her
husband is a permanent resident Global
Affairs Canada tells Global News while
they've raised the issue of families
like mill words with the Chinese
government they've so far been told only
Canadian citizens will be allowed to
board the Canadian plane I know it's
been a tough start of the year for many
of you the number of Canadians looking
to get out has now climbed to 301
speaking at a Lunar New Year event in
Toronto the Prime Minister didn't offer
details about when that plane may arrive
but Justin Trudeau did address the
racism some Chinese Canadians are
experiencing since news of the corona
virus broke there is no place in our
country for discrimination driven by
fear or misinformation this BC man was a
target of misinformation Chinese media
ran this photo saying he was a victim of
the outbreak even like my co-workers in
service and parts department they know
Oh Cunha where is there are people
looking to capitalize too with face
masks in high demand
if you're going online be careful
because there's scammers they're
fly-by-night retailers and Millward has
seen nasty comments saying Canadians in
China should just stay put
I just want to recently use that I'm
down for anything but I'm willing to be
held in quarantine for 14 days and
undergo any pence we're not trying to
please a health risk we're trying to
avoid but Ottawa is still trying to
figure out exactly what to do when that
plane arrives back in Canada we know
government officials including a unit
that specializes in helping Canadians in
distress during an emergency
will travel to whom a province to
coordinate logistics for the evacuation
but Global Affairs won't say when that
will happen
Robin Abigail daemon in Ottawa it's the
day after and a new dawn for Britain
after it broke away from the European
Union and delivered a huge blow to its
nearest neighbors it's a major moment
for Britain but a shock for the EU which
wants a fresh start and some new
momentum in the wake of brexit our
Europe bureau chief crystal commanding
joins us from London
crystal Robin there is so much hype
around the day and time of brexit Friday
at 11 o'clock but for so many it was
about more than just the politics and
the economics it's personal it's about
identity
it's a busy weekend like any other but
this day is different there are heavy
hearts on the streets of London history
says really sad what part of it is sad
for you all of it getting away from
Europe being just one one own country
alone my favorite opens up our economy
for more available opportunities what
the change means for business and the
movement of people still needs to be
worked out the UK has officially left
the European Union and that departure
will affect lives beyond the physical
borders of the UK Gibraltar is a British
overseas territory bordered by Spain
hundreds of Brits work and live here and
so do ten thousand Spaniards now the EU
says it will back Spain over its
territorial claim to Gibraltar it's good
for the country to be once again
independent and I think England will do
very well from our personal point of
view unfortunately with the neighbors we
have Spain they couldn't make life
difficult for us new deals have to be
reached on everything from security to
immigration to fishing rights French
fishermen have been temporarily banned
from entering the waters of Guernsey an
island in the English Channel because of
brexit fishing rights have been raised
by people in England as a key area for
negotiations with the EU only put bets
on a photo don't French president
Emmanuel macron posted a video to his
Facebook page Friday saying he was
deeply sad and he added a message in
English pledging a continued friendship
Umezu stock again the German Chancellor
Angela Merkel also shared her views in
her weekly podcast saying the European
Union is going into these negotiations
with a good spirit but also with its own
interests Great Britain will do the same
thing negotiations will be challenging
but the UK holds some important ships it
was one of the EU s largest economies it
is a big military spender
not to mention a leading international
financial capital Robin
crystal commencing in London u.s.
president Donald Trump is already
claiming victory in his impeachment
trial even though the Senate isn't
expected to acquit him until Wednesday
that outcome is all but certain after
the republican-led Senate voted late
Friday to block any new witness
testimony including former national
security adviser john bolton democrats
are fuming and say the president will
get away with pressuring a foreign
leader to meddle in the twenty20
election Jennifer Johnson reports a
cheering crowd and a fist pump from US
president Donald Trump as he arrived in
Florida knowing these all but guaranteed
an acquittal Wednesday in his
impeachment trial Democrats are fuming
after Republicans voted to block any new
testimony including from former national
security adviser John Bolton there's no
vindication no victory and certainly no
acquittal this is the first impeachment
trial in the history of the United
States with no witnesses and documents
we should be trying to seek the truth
not bury it according to the New York
Times Bolton's forthcoming book details
actions the president took to try and
get ukraine to investigate the Biden's
even asking Bolton to help him some
Republicans say what the president did
was inappropriate but the house didn't
prove it was an impeachable offense I
think what all of the senators in there
agree is that the regardless of what
happened over here House Democrats
didn't do their job over there the
president is already predicting his
re-election we will make sure that they
face
another crushing defeat touting
America's strong economy but experts say
the numbers tell a different story it's
not booming it's actually it's kind of
meager it's a you know it's a little bit
paltry growth it's not great growth it's
ok growth the president was hoping the
Senate vote would be taken before his
pre Superbowl interview Sunday on Fox
and Tuesday's State of the Union but he
appears to be enjoying himself today
even tweeting a picture I've been
playing golf on Monday there'll be four
hours of closing arguments in the Senate
later each senator will get a chance to
state their case then on Wednesday
afternoon the president
is expected to be acquitted Robin all
right thanks for that Jen last night the
LA Lakers honored Kobe Bryant as they
returned to the court for the first time
since a chopper crash claimed the life
of the former basketball star I want to
continue along my teammates to continue
his legacy LeBron James who joined the
team just 19 months ago led the tribute
to courtside seats were covered with red
roses and two jerseys in honor Bryant
and his daughter Gianna the rising
basketball player in her own right in an
Instagram post Bryant's wife Vanessa
also paid tribute to her husband and
daughter describing them as angels and
there is a new development in the
investigation into the crash the
National Transportation Safety Board is
expected to release his preliminary
findings next week but right now
investigators are looking at whether the
helicopter company broke the rules by
allowing the pilot to fly in thick fog
the pilot was certified to fly in low
visibility but officials say the company
Island Express helicopters was not a
total of nine people were killed there's
a state of emergency near the Australian
capital tonight as another heat wave
sparks more fires two huge fires are
tearing through forests and farmland
south of Canberra some outlying suburbs
are already cut off and locals are
already warned it's too late to leave
since September wildfires have claimed
the lives of 33 people destroyed more
than 3000 homes and torched more than 10
million hectares of land solar power is
still a tiny part of overall energy
generation in Canada but along with
another renewable energy source
wind power it's coming on fast and
provincial and federal government
rebates are receiving much of the credit
as Ross Lord reports as more residents
in Nova Scotia plug into these
incentives it's also creating more jobs
it's a sound that's becoming familiar in
Canada attaching solar panels to
rooftops as homeowners go green I want
to do something to help both the
environment Glen Gill derson estimates
he'll save $100 a month on his power
bill at a provincial government rebate
of almost five thousand dollars will
help pay off his investment in ten years
I wouldn't have done it without the
rebate the solar homes program it seems
is a shining success more than 600 other
Nova Scotia homeowners have used the
rebate to go solar in less than two
years the number of solar installers has
grown fivefold mostly small businesses
that are becoming larger when we started
we just had myself and a helper and now
we're up to maybe up to 14 people the
rebates behind those jobs come from a 56
million dollar program which is part of
the Trudeau government's 1 billion
dollar climate fund aimed at reducing
greenhouse gases this solar advocate who
also drives an electric car says
subsidies are nurturing critically
important industries not only jobs in
clean energy directly but there's jobs
in training people to work in clean
energy there's jobs in education to
train designers builders in the building
industry not everyone agrees in Alberta
the United Conservative Party government
of premier Jason Kenney says it's ending
solar rebates over the objections of
people who say the rebates created
thousands of jobs for us in the labor
movement the the solar rebate was a
godsend well the oil and gas sector of
our economy was struggling we actually
saw people going from the oil and gas
sector to the renewable energy sector
back in Nova Scotia the rebates
popularity has forced the government to
reduce the amounts individual homeowners
can receive so the funding doesn't run
out buying more time as they measure the
impact of green jobs
Ross Lord Global News Halifax
coming up the material piling up in
Quebec with nowhere to recycle
three men are dead after a shooting
inside a Toronto condo that had been
rented on Airbnb investigators say the
violence happened during a party Friday
night one other man suffered serious
gunshot wounds a fifth man suffered a
minor injury no one is in custody but
police are not searching for a suspect
most Canadians don't think about what
gets recycled
once it's tossed into a bins but in
Quebec it's top of mind for many right
now a company that runs several sorting
centers in the province is abandoning
operations and as a Mandela wiki
explains that's plunging Montreal into a
crisis the quantity of plastic glass and
paper collecting snow here is simply
staggering and the piles are growing
each day this is one of two plants that
sorts recycling material for Canada's
second biggest city last week the French
operator
Thiru announced it would soon cease
operations it has plunged Montreal's
recycling program into crisis the
program is now on the verge of collapse
emergency stay a state if I can say
Teru says it's no longer profitable to
keep its poor Quebec sorting centers
running the problem started two years
ago that's when China and other Asian
countries closed its doors to most
Canadian recycling products
Thiru has struggled getting rid of its
goods so they've been piling up and
Montreal is scrambling to find a new
contractor to take over the plant
definitely it's a difficult situation
but we need to see it as an opportunity
the companies that produce papers how
can we work together to make sure that
we're not so dependent from
international markets critics say the
city should have seen this coming this
reflection and this you know thinking of
what should be done should have been
done two years ago last year Global News
conducted a sweeping investigation of
recycling in Canada it uncovered huge
gaps and huge costs for some
municipalities environmentalists say
it's time Montreal finds its own
solutions we collect a lot in Quebec
what we don't
cycle and this is a problem we sure we
should have develop the recycling
industry farm art and we didn't we
didn't if the crisis isn't cleaned up
soon there's fear that Montreal errs
will lose faith in recycling and just
trash the practice entirely Amanda jela
wiki Global News Montreal still ahead
the steps to saving more for your
retirement
[Music]
to make the best of your retirement ears
it's never too soon to start saving as
online reporter Eric olena explains in
this week's money one two three by
thinking ahead you can leave the
workforce and your worries behind you
may have heard that for retirement you
should aim to replace 70% of your income
or save 15% of your pre-tax pay but you
can do better than rely on a
one-size-fits-all rule of thumb the
first step is to estimate your annual
living costs in retirement a low-key
retirement generally means lower
expenses step 2 multiply your annual
expenses by the number of years you
think your retirement is going to last
for example if you think you'll need
$40,000 a year for 25 years your savings
goal is 1 million dollars then subtract
any retirement income you'll be
receiving from your employer plus an
estimate of benefits such as the Canada
Pension Plan and old age security in our
example let's say that lowers your
target nest egg to seven hundred and
fifty thousand dollars step 3 calculate
the savings rate that will get you there
the financial planning website the
measure of a plan has a handy savings
calculator for that investing can make
it a whole lot easier to reach your
retirement goal let's say you're thirty
you want to retire at 65 with seven
hundred and fifty thousand dollars and
so far have nothing saved without
investing you'd have to set aside nearly
eighteen hundred dollars a month for 35
years but if your money was earning a
four percent average annual return you'd
get there by saving just eight hundred
and thirty three dollars per month well
the whole point of investing is because
of inflation inflation ravages your
purchasing power over time and so if you
can invest your money and earn a rate of
return of four or five six percent or
higher that's gonna allow your savings
to grow and protect you from
the rising costs over time remember
all calculations about retirement our
educated guesses so it's a good idea to
reassess your assumptions and adjust the
math throughout years that's your money
one two three four this week I'm Erica
aleni
up next how a Toronto team is hoping to
pack in rugby fans
former Humboldt Broncos hockey player
Ryan Stratton iski hit the ice alongside
Olympic gold medalist hailey Wiccan
Heiser for a celebrity sledge hockey
game in Surrey BC the matchup is part of
wick fests a world female hockey
festival today's event was held at the
first Ice Arena in Canada to be gold
certified for accessibility
by the Rick Hansen foundation it's
absolutely amazing to get the city out
there aware of you know accessible rinks
it's just a good you know step in the
right direction for adaptive sports
reznitsky was paralyzed in the 2018 bus
crash that killed 16 people including
ten of his Broncos teammates the 20 old
traveled to Thailand in the fall for
treatment that has helped him regain
movement in his legs he now has his
sights set on making the Team Canada
Paralympic ice hockey team in 2026
tomorrow tens of millions of football
fans will be glued to their TVs for the
Super Bowl but that isn't the only big
game this weekend
the Toronto Wolfpack will play its first
match in Britain's elite Super League on
Sunday the rugby league team doesn't
have any Canadians on the roster and it
spends most of its time in England so
will it be able to connect with
Canadians
and grow its fan base here's Redman
Shannon it was a crazy idea to start a
transatlantic Rugby franchise in Canada
not in rugby union a minority sport that
most Canadians will be aware of but in
rugby league the less popular 13 man
game transatlantic team too much travel
other clubs aren't going to like it but
as a whole it's been brilliant after
just three years of working through
England's minor leagues Toronto Wolfpack
is now big time playing its first game
in England's super league with a goal of
sparking a rugby league tradition in
Canada that's the idea
we're trying to expand rugby league and
North America Canada back as a massive
talent and pool of talent from the NFL
and the CFL so it's not too dissimilar
it's got a ball one as out as you come
through somebody and tackle em as out as
you can the team also has to tackle an
expense bill unique in the league most
of our players live here we ship them to
Canada for almost three months of the
year
in the summertime and they love Toronto
but it logistically it's a it's a lot of
work with no Canadian players on the
team and a squad that's based mostly
here in England with Toronto sports fans
actually connect with the Wolfpack
chairman and former Maple Leaf Sports
executive Bob hunter points to the
popularity of a mostly non Canadian
Raptors team it's Canada's only NBA
franchise and has fans right across the
country so the reality is the fans the
sponsors the city of the country want to
see a winning squad and if that takes 24
international players then that's what
the fans want to see they'll also see
one of rugby's biggest names Sonny Bill
Williams brought in on the biggest
contract in super league history its
ranchers they some people say it's the
sporting mick over the world if we can
add our little five cents in there as
well it'd be special the famously humble
World Cup winner now at home in
Toronto's Lamport stadium I'm pretty
excited to get over there is a rugby
player there's a right believe play and
see what it's all about the boys tell me
that it's May him at the stadium that
mayhem will ramp up a notch in April for
the wolf pack's home opener Redman
Shannon Global News Manchester England
and that is global national for this
Saturday I'm Robin Gill tonight your
Canada is SAS Matt Lake near Port Moody
BC thank you for watching have a great
night
[Music]